t distributions are defined by their degrees of freedom. Degrees of freedom are
pretty complicated to explain. So, first we'll start with some real life
examples before applying them to these statistical concepts. Let's say you have
three homework assignments to do, writing, statistics, and psychology. And each
will take you an hour. And you only have three hours to finish them. So here
are your three, hour long, time slots. How many options do you have for which
homework assignment, you can do for the first time slot? After you choose which
homework assignment you'll do. How many options do you have for the second time
slot? And finally, how many options do you have for the third? After you choose
what homework assignments you'll do for your first two time slots?